guess what's in the kitchen what just
come and take a peek manny we gotta take
a peek hold on sweetheart let's go
oh my god
what is
jenna yeah oh my
goodness this is candy this is
solid chocolate wait it's solid it's so
i mean i haven't investigated but like
because usually when you see things like
this like the easter bunnies they're
always hollow i don't believe it i'm
pretty sure it's solid it says it weighs
let me get a let me get a scale i could
probably pick it up and just
oh my god this is a chocolate lancer
wait you lift up on that side i could
just here i'll just put my little hands
under here
ready okay
we could have taken it out of the box
36.9 pounds
it's official this thing is really
packed in there
jam-packed april update
oh man oh no okay maybe get the dress
oh my god it's happy should we get a
plate
yeah we have a plate it's called the
island
it's dark chocolate so it's healthy
how many calories do you think
let's not think uh-oh easter bunny was
good to oh
wow hard hard talk wow look at this
detail
wow wow wow
well i'm gonna get my knife why don't we
just cut off um
like the pieces on oh
wow okay honey well that's one way to
get it done
we could make the world's biggest hot
chocolate i'm speechless
i don't know should we wrap it up so we
can like freeze it or something maybe
like
well we can just like kind of like you
know they did in santa clarita diet
where she knows she took all the bodies
and put them in a freezer so like we
could do that
i'll bring this to like matte okay if
you give this to another person
give this to another friend do you need
a chainsaw
only we had a chainsaw
do you have one i can get one
do you hear that no my shoes are so loud
i can't wear these
yeah i hear it
hey your wi-fi is really slow i know
it's incredibly slow time warner is a
piece of crap
basically so i'm heading right now to go
do vo for a movie
and if i'm doing vo i'm going to be in
the vocal booth
and you're going to be hearing my shoes
pink has boots on the pig has boots on
what i guess i can wear these but i
think these are also
wow i can wear my pizza hut shoes
if you double tap i will be mad
getting married today oh excuse you and
that yawn mister
we're finally live can you add
annotations
to mine please
this is so hot it just burned me the
dongle things that you attached to your
macbook can get so hot that you actually
burn yourself
well i'm off to do this vo session can
you please add end card and annotations
to my movie well let me know when it's
up
okay hopefully soon my internet sucks
no you have to make it live too
[Music]
this is a really huge studio for just
like a little vo session like
this is a huge room so we're about to do
the session so here's the microphone
clearly
if you can't tell what that is you read
lines off of here you watch the movie
here
and then you have to try to match up
what you're saying to the actual movie
it's actually a lot more difficult than
you think it would be
[Music]
hey i'm off to shoot some videos with ro
today and i didn't have any pants
please be dry yes
we got our pants we gotta go get our
starbucks and we're on our way to rose
house to film for her show nerdy nummies
i'm excited i love filming with ro
because she is so much fun
and we always have a good time and
that's very important
i feel like there was something else i
needed i wanted to switch lenses
[Music]
there you go what do you think
great cool let's go is my coffee cup not
charged
i'm going to be so upset
what's happening okay right now we just
finished our nerdy nummies i gotta show
you what we made
should we show them or no oh no no we
can't show you but wait
oh well okay so row invites me over and
she's like we've got something super
simple
it'll be so easy and honestly like i
mean i
messed it up our fire alarm it would
have went off
yeah is there still is there still is
has it been cleaned up let's give a hint
just
show them the decorations yes wait look
here
very there's the right here's the spill
because it bubbled up it boiled over we
were talking we lost track time we were
having fun
and it just boiled a little too much but
we caught it and justine was thinking
fast she turned it off
right away turned off the heat and we
saved the day it was a little smoky but
a little bit oh we're safe let me clean
you guys oh yeah
you're a little dirty here there you go
yeah look at these decorations
okay so this is the hint of what we did
these
colors it's a theme oh shoot oh oh
my you might have saw something you
might have saw if you saw something
maybe you didn't this is a little summer
treat it's gonna be great
something we both like oh oh shoot i
don't know when it's gonna be out but a
nice summer dream it will be in the
summer
i'm so excited i love your setup your
kitchen is so great it's incredible
face now justine before it was really
narrow
it was a big kitchen but it was really
narrow so when we were filming we'd have
to like hug
tight we'd have to be like this like hi
and the counter space was super narrow
but now this is
great i love it so much oh and that's
that over there that's where you shoot
all the challenges over there
over here this is the sun room and out
here
you can see the pool in the backyard
it's so fun okay i can't show you the
i accidentally heated my pool to 103
degrees the other day
because i thought i was heating the hot
tub but i was actually heating the pool
and the whole pool was a hot tub but i
went for a night swim it was kind of the
best thing in the world that's awesome i
can't do that again
but it was amazing you guys this pool
was 103 degrees
oh yeah henry's looking fly and note
look at his little bow tie oh got little
pikachu
little pokemon ball oh you're so cute
i was also showing ro the clips app oh
it's so cool you're gonna absolutely
love it i also forgot to tell you guys
you can actually use it on
you have an ipad too yeah i could also
use it on an ipad it's pretty neat
okay i was pretty impressed by the
subtitles and actually knew what you
were saying
like how did it do that i was just
getting better light for you oh thanks
girl
i was in the shadow well i mean it's
basically like how you use siri you talk
to siri
but it also dictates so yeah it's cool i
think you'll really like it it was
really neat i really i thought it was
really
cool you know what else i liked about it
that it was square
yeah it's so hard to like make really
cool square videos
yeah makes it easy because you can make
wide videos on instagram
but when i just generally view something
it's always square
oh
um well i had a fun day filming this was
so much fun girl and i
i was a little embarrassed but i got my
socks on and
you know uh they have an l and an r on
them so i can
remember which foot they go on i have
those two and they're never on the right
foot
ever no because sometimes i'll have an l
and an l and then an r and an r and i'm
like well this is the life that we live
oh my gosh i used to do
different colored shoe laces yeah
someone was grabbing my sneakers i would
know that the blue ones go on the left
and the pink ones go on the right
well my troubles i don't know the left
or the right i get those confused to the
fact that the yellow and the r
it doesn't even okay the struggle guys
help me
but now i have little letters on there
there's a little l
and then a little r i know i took my
shoe off
all right well that's it we have a bunch
of fun videos for you guys so make sure
you check out ro's channel and then you
know they're
they're there yeah they're there they're
hanging out
always in the car always in traffic
always drinking starbucks
and i feel like we're always going
somewhere today we're off to sami's
camera i'm getting a couple things
and then we're shooting all day this is
my last resort
suffocation no breathing don't give i've
worked in a compact spot and i can't get
out
huge cars parked in compact spots wait
and you're eating a little snack i'm
eating cheesy peanut butter
i'm going to stuff to my teeth well i
got to go to a different starbucks
because they didn't have the thing that
i wanted in my starbucks
what did you want eggway bites what
this is nathan is this wet oh i think it
might be wet
this is so exciting this isn't like my
favorite place in the world i'm gonna
get my film first
okay cool we're gonna look around
so we're shooting a bunch of videos
today but there's a few things that i
needed that i've been meaning to get
so we're gonna get look at this
oh my god look at this um
yeah but like why don't i just take the
picture with my iphone and then that's
done well you can do that too so then
now i have a canon scanner
and you actually scan it in and the
resolution is like
20 000 megapixels by 20 000 megapixels
oh that makes sense that's why you don't
take it with your iphone
it's so crazy each picture is like a
gigabyte
oh my goodness yeah look at our new
tripod nathan
i like it excited i'm really excited
great it's going to be great
yeah so seeing that has everything so
the big one is 3 8
and the little one is quarter 20. cool
[Music]
look i'm planning on doing like eight
videos today so i hope you're ready
you know what there's like eight videos
we want to shoot today we're shooting
eight videos okay
all right we'll see once we get to like
number five i'm probably gonna get
cranky and not want to do it anymore so
we'll see what happens we'll take a
break and then we'll get back into it
we got nathan's film we got my tripod
and everything is going well so far now
just to shoot all the videos
man i i do really want to go to
hollywood but if they if they would have
had the cage i would have thought about
it but
we can go no he said they didn't have it
so we can go another day
i don't think we did enough shopping we
didn't but it's okay because i
i've done enough shopping when you're
not there it's my first time
clearly he's like oh justine you're back
again i just saw your sister two days
ago i'm like
we have a problem just open a tab put it
on my tab
[Music]
he's going great what do you think of
our new tripod
i like this tripod yeah it's a good
tripod cool
[Music]
nice so jenna's here we're shooting our
easter videos now some things are
getting crazy
so you'll see this video actually
depending upon what i post this
vlog these videos might already be out
or they might not you never know
you look beautiful
and just so you guys know the cage door
is open
he put himself in there he did he likes
it this is his little house
let me see that belly look at that boy
you're so sweet honey so sweet
all right guys next vid coming up look
at this great organization that i've got
this was actually a little craft kit
i'm super impressed with your look at
the battery the battery drawer is my
favorite
yes we've got our sony canon and gopro
and
other accessories yeah i like it that's
great
is there one that says jen on there oh
yeah your stuff is all over here
oh my god we just had a full day
shooting i don't even know how many
videos we shot but it's a lot
thanks nathan so many so many and
francesca and ava are here hi francesco
we're helping
[Music]
so something just happened we've been
trying to get ava to go potty
and she wasn't partying and then i went
upstairs and i smelled
i smelled your poop i smelled your poop
it's okay it was very solid
it's very solid and firm
was scared i was terrified the smell the
smell really wasn't that bad i think
just because the door was closed
well yeah and then it just came close it
was just marinating
yeah hi oh you can use sniffies okay
this last video of the day
last video today
[Music]
no it's okay
i can't wait to go back to sammy's and
do some shopping we've got some things
we need to get
to to trick out the kitchen with some
better lighting there's a cobwebs
there's a lot of cobwebs
because i saw the water wow
okay let's do it okay cool let's do it
um what just happened um jenna cut my
tongue off
do you have a fun time filming john no
that's a horrible idea i don't know why
i think it was a good idea
nathan is great it was that was intense
that was a lot that's a day it's gonna
be
incredible end scene
[Music]